life is strange is a game well loved by
a lot of people including myself but i
think that's more in spite of its flaws
than because it doesn't have many i say
this as someone who waited with baited
breath for every episode of the original
game and if you're here to tell me that
the games are bad go away i don't care i
like them so do lots of other people it
doesn't matter if you don't
life estranged true colors is the latest
installment in the series and here's the
thing i just spent 20 hours playing it
in a marathon and fundamentally it takes
everything that you loved about the
original game and does it better you
play through the story of alex chen who
can read the emotions of others in their
auras moving to the beautiful mountain
community of haven springs where you
uncover a mystery and try to build a new
home for yourself
oh and uh spoilers for everything by the
way
now we understand this is a
controversial opinion because the
original game is so well remembered by
all of us but to understand why true
colors is probably the best game in the
series now i want to talk through six
things that it does better than the
previous games firstly dialogue people
have often criticized the dialogue of
life is strange for being clunky
unnatural clearly written by people who
are trying to guess at what teenagers
sound like and not always succeeding and
you know what it's a fair criticism it
does kinda sound like that at times true
colors definitely delivers better
dialogue it's as simple as that it's
better written characters sound like
people and there's just more subtext to
it
secondly the player character max
caulfield was criticized for being a
somewhat bland protagonist and you know
what not unfair but alex is a fully
formed character with wants and needs
and flaws and fears you care so much
about her she was a child who was kind
of lost in the foster system and you can
really see how that affected her she has
a full history of her own that deeply
informs the story and decisions that you
and she make max was seemingly a blank
slate for you to project onto which can
totally work but for a story that is so
founded on building character
relationships i think alex worked better
she's a little more limited in who she
can be but it means that there were
stronger character dynamics and more
consistent arcs with how she interacted
with other characters she had a clearly
defined place in this world and her own
story alex being a fully formed
character is also great for the queer
relationship that a lot of people look
for in life is strange she fosters that
queer relationship with stiff a lot more
naturally than max does which i think a
lot of people will find really valuable
now the writers of true colors did make
one interesting decision which you may
agree or disagree with which is that
they decided to be more cut-scene
focused with longer gaps between when
you get to decide what alex says or does
this is actually more akin to life is
strange too and let me explain why i
think it worked the original game has
you decide almost every line of mex's
dialogue you're constantly interacting
with what max says or does
but most of those dialogue decisions
aren't actually that important you're
interacting a lot but it's often picking
lines that mean mostly the same thing i
felt stripping them back and being more
selective about where you could make
decisions really helped with the pacing
of the individual scenes and the
character development because it meant
that my decisions mattered more when i
did something i actually found myself
thinking about them more even if i was
just picking a line of dialogue and i
think it meant that the writers actually
had a better idea of how a scene was
meant to play out they could plan it
more making it more cohesive and helping
it hit harder so true colors does have
less interactivity than the original
game but that's not because your choices
matter less and that leads us on to
three the cast of characters life is
strange has always been about the
characters that's basically all there is
but while we grew to love max chloe k
joyce even david in the original the
writers did make some odd choices with
them for example kate a character we
were actually invested in virtually
vanishes from the story after episode
two that emotional through line is
basically dropped likewise even though
warren is a romantic interest and
interactions with other characters like
steph and alyssa do have consequences we
just never got enough time to know them
properly and care about those
consequences as much as we perhaps
should have and though jefferson turns
out to be the villain it doesn't hit as
hard as i think they intended because we
don't have a hugely personal connection
with him either as a mentor or friend or
enemy true colors instead narrows its
focus to fewer characters and ensures
you have time to get to know all of them
really damn well i mean i was crying by
the end of episode 1 and even more so in
episode two the result of this is that
the consequences of your decisions feel
a lot more personal when jed lucan
eventually betrays you in episode four
it hurts because he has been a father
figure in general true colors is just a
more intimate story with more personal
stakes eleanor's alzheimer's charlotte's
depression struggles ducky's sadness the
loss of his wife gabe's desire to form a
new family they're all deeply moving
coupled with better dialogue and alex
being a fully formed character true
colors just inevitably has a stronger
cast fourthly binary choices the
original game is sometimes criticized
for the binary nature of its decisions a
good and a bad outcome that kate dies or
she doesn't die alyssa is caught in the
storm or she doesn't get caught in the
storm there were some more morally
complicated decisions to be made a lot
of it did come down to a good and a bad
ending for each character what i really
loved about true colours is that it has
a more morally complicated ending you
might say choosing to leave or stay in
haven springs at the end is more about
how you view your journey with alex and
ryan or steph the values that you have
found in the story then picking the
quote right ending telling riley about
her grandmother's alzheimer's isn't a
good or bad decision in and of itself
it's about that relationship and that
journey and who you feel you need to be
honest with it's down to your judgment
of them as characters the result of this
is an ending that feels more your own
not really condemning you or praising
you but just being you
that it's special for the sake of it
being your journey and not because you
got the good ending with that character
now that's not to say that it's all like
that there are still better endings with
certain characters but i think it's
still an improvement for a game that
sells itself on your decisions mattering
fifthly mental illness i mean this
really shouldn't be a surprise at this
point but this was something that really
drew me to the original game and i think
it resonated with a lot of people i was
in an especially vulnerable place at the
time and it was something i could really
empathize and connect with so while i
did really appreciate the discussion
around kate and her suicidality it
wasn't actually the best representation
of depression and suicide either in what
it's truly like or how to deal with it
and that's okay i think there's a lot of
value in discussing this stuff even if
it's not perfect but trying its best now
true colors doesn't discuss it as
explicitly as the original game but it's
an undercurrent to the events of the
story the pain that charlotte expresses
is complicated that she hates her child
because when she looks at him it reminds
her of the pain of losing gabe that is a
very difficult emotion to confront
and deal with and it's not a right
answer but it's very real very down to
earth likewise the difficulties that
foster children have are always there in
the background they're informing the
characters a part of their life and who
they are and i really liked that i
appreciated how complicated the mental
illness felt in the story acknowledging
both how hard it is to help those people
who struggle and empathizing with those
who do at the same time even if it
didn't confront it as openly as it did
with say kate on the roof that it was
part of the fabric of life even if it
wasn't the entire plot and sixthly i get
that this point is definitely more
subjective so you may or may not agree
with me but i want to talk about it so i
will sue me i never liked how episode 5
in the original game focused on the
consequences of max's time travel powers
because the game was never meant to be
about the consequences of her powers
they weren't even to be about her powers
at all really her powers were just a
tool to explore the difficulties of
growing up and building relationships
and dealing with this thing called life
having it suddenly be about how the
universe is falling apart because she's
using her powers too much or the ethics
of it felt tonally and thematically off
distracting me from what i really cared
about and i think most people really
cared about the abstract dream sequence
was just a little too weird for me it
was slow and quite disconnected from the
main plot but here's the thing true
colors does also open episode 5 with a
similar weird dream sequence
but i like it it's a lot more integrally
tied to the main plot and because alex
is a much more developed character i
cared a lot more about what happened in
it likewise though alex has the power to
see people's emotions and kind of read
their minds the game never really
explores the ethics and consequences of
those powers it keeps its climax focused
on the things people care about it is
just a tool to explore the relationships
and world here episode 5 is the natural
culmination to the mystery and character
relationships that we've built across
the previous episodes without the weird
magic stuff that i felt undermined the
original climax but fundamentally it's
hard to understate just how much true
colors takes from the original game in
its plot its characters atmosphere its
dynamics you name it you're arriving in
a quaint small town full of life an
atmosphere that you just want to get
lost in but it also has a dark secret
that you slowly unveil i think the
developers learned from life is strange
too which i and i know a lot of other
people found harder to get into partly
because it didn't have that consistent
sense of place and characters but haven
springs is just as vivid as arcadia bay
and as i've said the characters even
more so it's the sort of place that you
really do just want to sit and listen to
the music which of course it lets you do
there are also clear parallels between
some characters mack clearly plays a
similar role to nathan prescott while
jed lucan plays a similar role to
jefferson the plot though i would not
say is copying the original i would say
is structurally very similar and follows
some of the same tropes episodes one and
two are all about setting the scene
introducing you to the characters with a
strong emotional through line that draws
it all together kate's suicidality and
gabe's death episode 3 is uncovering the
mystery and a lot more light-hearted
than the previous two episodes episode 4
ends with a father figure character
betraying you because you've found out
their dark secret the little dark secret
about the town and you spend half of
episode 5 in a weird dream sequence
dealing with a lot of personal stuff
before you return and stop the impending
disaster where your relationships that
you've built up across the story
determine how that sort of pans out and
i don't know how to quantify this but it
just sort of feels similar you'll know
it when you play it and i'm not saying
that this is a bad thing at all i think
it's awesome it took all of the things
that i loved about the original game and
did it better it's definitely its own
world full of its own characters but it
channels a lot of what made me so
attached to arcadia bay and its story if
true colors can be criticized for
something it'll be these two things one
not much problem solving there were
quite a number of neat little moments in
the first and second games where max or
sean and daniel needed to solve puzzles
both with their powers and without now
it was never a puzzle game but i think
those scenes using that different type
of thinking gave a bit of variety to the
games it was a strength while you do
solve problems in true colors it never
takes much thinking and it's not usually
with creative use of your powers
something i feel that they could have
done more of it would have only improved
the game a bit and two
stiff
stiff is the main female romantic
interest in the story and therefore
quite an important one because 70 of
players picked her
she's a great character she really is
but she is unfortunately one that i
think we know kinda the least it's not
that we don't know her but that we don't
have as many scenes where she gets to be
vulnerable with us and us be vulnerable
with her compare that to ryan who has a
really touching and authentic moment
where she feels someone else's joy
through him for the first time as they
connect over gabe's death stiff was just
missing a scene like that i felt i get
being nostalgic over the original life
of strange game it came to me in a time
that i needed it and really connected
with it and that's okay if you still
prefer arcadia bay and all its
characters to haven springs that's fine
you hold on to that memory and that love
but i reckon you really will like true
colors these games are deeply personal
and how good the writing is often
doesn't really matter that much when we
have that personal connection because
our soul is there you know in some weird
way but with all of this said for me
true colors isn't just a great game but
it's the game that life is strange has
been trying to be for a long time but
never quite hitting the mark
stay nerdy
and i'll see you in the future